Congrats in the film it was to thank you
yesterday and I loved it Jennifer you
recently won a glamour outstanding yes
it was best member my life well I was
there at the table with you and I have
you found a nice home for your award I
have do you know it's sitting just as
you walk into my hallway and it's
sitting there because I said I think you
need to read it I think about I am I
went there the other day is Jennifer
really is too
she's the most outstanding ward
approving cyclin well that leads me very
nicely into my next question how would
you describe your friendship with Joanna
slightly outstanding I think yeah well
the great thing about you know someone's
a very good friend when you don't have
to see them all the time and you just
pick up at the same point and this
there's no there's no bother there's no
nothing there's no sense of oh you
didn't come to fencing you for a bit so
we need that kind of nonsense
I think cuz we see each other that much
and actually one of the great things
about doing ab fab is that we get to
hang out it's quite an expensive way of
meeting instead of having do you have to
write a film that's gonna say let me
just go to the pub next time yes so
Joanna yeah Pat stone and I don't know
if you know on glamour we have a sexiest
men list every year yeah and he is now
Holly tiptoes Glamis sexiest man I am so
tired but in which incarnation but I
like I like to invest in his Sergeant
Pepper days I liked him then what do you
think pretty cool in the film did you
cook in the film in the film this is
this is what we're thinking and you were
sort of wondering if we may begin to see
a spin-off perhaps yeah what a parody
dangers bum spin yeah she'd have to make
it a little bit more of an effort I
think the hair would have to go this was
the hair was the thing they liked you as
Pat in that way she was an old man and
so enormous shoes stuck on a rich happy
mister
so Jennifer when you were filming the
dream sequence with Kate Alexa Lily
Daisy the Kuna gang did you all get
pizzas for lunch or did you just smoke
[ __ ] and talk about my sickness well the
thing was it was in the evening and so I
think everyone did have a lovely glass
of wine and there was this massive bowl
I think it was like sweeties and fruit
and everything on the table and everyone
just picked but the great thing was I
could never tell when the scene is sort
of started and when I finished because
everyone was just yakkung yakkung
yakkung yakkung yakkung all the time
it's like that thing when you think
people are friends and they do know each
other but it was that moment on set when
they just walked in yakkung they stayed
yakkung they did the scene and they went
off yakkung there's a whole new
generation of fans now for Patterson
Eddy why do you think the characters
have kind of really stood the test of
time and I think I can confirm my 10
year old is a massive fan you're joking
look Terry fantastic because I think
they sink their sink paddles acting like
children well she's my Saffy we've
caught us this makes perfect sense it's
all normal did you see I told you said
she just got sensible Julia Sawalha take
notice mother what kind of training did
you need to do for the film for instance
picking up on your body drinking smoking
[ __ ] running around in high heels that's
making facts these days and I noticed
this time I kept saying yeah nice
costumes Hailey's shoes English
cigarettes we enjoyed a nice smooth walk
across the floor towards Jon Hamm that I
had practicing
I can't even speak did you just want to
lick his face I just okay
so both of you would you rather make up
Ferb the West End musical ab fab the
movie part ii or ab fab season 7 movie
part 2 or season 7 I think maybe part 2
yeah yeah okay great I've just got my
she's got my headline